turkmenistan a central asian nation near
the caspian sea known for its rivaling
nomadic tribes making it a common place
for rising conflict more often than not
but in western turkmenistan a small
group of eight rather peculiar tribes
exist while at first glance they may
seem to just be another group of nomads
posing no threat to anyone aside from
the other opposing tribes in the
immediate area they are anything but
ordinary shrouded in mystery it is of
scp foundation belief that they may be a
significant threat due to the many
questions still unanswered regarding
their origins the most dire of question
of all isn't where they came from but
when
scp-3838 nomads of the fourth
dimensional step is a collection of
eight nomatic tribes occupying a small
area of 10 kilometers they all seem to
be of similar origin but they are very
different in behavior and in the way
they interact with outsiders while
multiple tribes can share the same space
they don't all exist in the space at the
same time periodically the current tribe
will perform a ritual with two flames
near the entrance they will enter a yurt
and vanish they will then soon be
replaced by another tribe this new tribe
will appear seemingly having traveled
from another time though the foundation
is unable to determine how exactly this
ritual works all the tribes typically
survive off the goats and sheep in the
area and live in huts their religions
and traditions vary each group has its
own khan and speaks the same dialect of
turkmen but interaction with the groups
has led to some bizarre revelations for
one thing their dialect was last
commonly spoken in the 15th century some
of these groups are humble traitors
others are hostile and warlike and the
foundation rarely knows which they'll be
dealing with next while these groups all
occupy the same place but not the same
time they have developed unique ways
around this issue the tribes seem to
treat time the same way other groups
treat location forming treaties that
allow them to benefit when they switch
into the space but while some choose
peace others choose war observations
made by the foundation have proven that
when a new tribe appears
violence and attacks from them are not
only common but have been growing
significantly more volatile over time
unlike many scps the nomads of the 4th
dimensional step are not new they have
been occupying this land since at least
1696
when they were first sighted however
initial sightings were not made by the
foundation which at that time didn't
exist in its current form it was after a
massive battle approximately three
millennia earlier that the devan et
jereme or office of magic picked up
reports of disappearing tents over the
years they have slowly but consistently
amassed more and more knowledge of the
eight tribes now designated as
scp-3838 each tribe exists in the same
geographic space but they come from a
different era of history and bring with
them different culture traditions
technology and weaponry the space itself
changed drastically from its earliest
days as a holy site in the 15th century
bce to a bustling marketplace in the
1800s the marketplace is of particular
interest to the foundation as it is said
to possess strange and magical items
like guns that shoot bolts of light and
arrows that follow their targets both
the 15th century holy site and the
marketplace are unique locations in time
they are the only two places that
manifest when the tribes interact and
hold councils and negotiations each of
these tribes bring unique challenges and
opportunities for the foundation
scp-3838-1 is one of the smallest tribes
a humble group of vendors they only
appear in the communal marketplace in
the 18th century but are believed to be
from the second and third century ce and
they are known as excellent potters if
you see them the odds are they're trying
to sell you some nice earthenware pots
but while they're not relevant to the
larger conflict they are a unique group
for one reason they follow the manikin
religion instead of islam and are strong
believers in the religion's dualist
battle between good and evil the latter
being associated with the color red the
second tribe has something unique
scp-3838-2
originates from closer to our time
between the 12th and 18th century ce and
they are the only tribe led entirely by
women this matriarchal society
participates in all the standard tribal
activities including combat and herding
and their lore speaks of a female
warrior who led in the initial great
battle thousands of years ago their
territory is among the largest of the
tribes but little is known about them
beyond that they practice a mix of
traditional shamanism and islam and are
known for a ritual hunt with roots in
mongolia these woman warriors are fierce
but not at the center of the conflict
but the tribes that grow closer to the
present day hold much more territory
scp-3838-3 is the current tribe
occupying the land from between 1870 and
2054 ce
into the future it is a simple tribe
that seems to have moved closer to a
modern system of government its con
leads alongside a collection of lesser
governors advising him the tribe is
known for their carpet weaving skills
with their stunning wares being a
popular item for bartering in the
marketplace but this group previously
held much more territory their position
as a dominant force is being threatened
by a powerful force and that force is
getting closer
scp-3838-4 is believed to occupy the
land from between 2054 and 3000 the
longest lasting tribe and they didn't
get there by negotiations and bartering
this tribe is feared by all the other
tribes the only one not welcome in the
communal spaces and it's not hard to see
why they're hostile and warlike
attacking both other tribes and
foundation members if you look closely
at them and are able to survive you
might see that they're dressed in human
skins those captured by them who survive
are likely to wind up as their slaves
which makes their army large and
virtually unconquerable their traditions
are mostly unknown but they seem focused
on a funeral urn they protect at all
costs which they claim contains the body
of a fallen enemy but no empire lasts
forever and something new will
eventually rise
scp-3838-5 took over the space from 3000
to 3020 after the fall of their
predecessors and they couldn't be more
different this small peaceful tribe has
few members left and is mostly seen at
the marketplace they're known for being
excellent cooks and have good relations
with most other tribes the foundation is
more likely to encounter them in the
marketplace than in their own territory
which is rapidly shrinking and barely
has enough room to farm or to build new
settlements but the tribes were about to
take a quantum leap the source of the
strange and powerful weapons at the
marketplace was a mystery until the
foundation met scp-38
this tribe ruled from 3020 to 3450 and
were closely aligned with their
predecessors a traditional shiite muslim
group unconcerned with the mysticism of
other tribes their technology is
powerful and advanced and they work with
a secretive group called the empire for
the reclamation of islamic artifacts due
to their advanced culture and
intellectual nature they're the most
common point group for interaction with
the foundation they are friendly and
cooperative and the foundation is
careful to keep it that way rather than
meet them on the battlefield the next
tribe however is a mystery originally
scp-3838-7
existed from 3500 to 4100 ce they were a
powerful and long-lasting empire but
every empire ends and this one came to a
crashing halt in a conquest that
eliminated all their territory and left
them as simple nomads lost in time and
mostly existing within the marketplace
and as refugees within the other tribes
or when it comes to the war like
scp-3838-4
as captives the majority can be found
within the small group of scp-3838-5
but the question remains what brought
this tribe to an end most stories of
this period attribute the destruction to
scp-3838-4
but recent events may tell a different
story
scp-3838-8 is the most mysterious tribe
of all and for good reason we do not
know when they begin or end they come
from the far future and none of the
other tribes communicate with them in
fact no members of
scp-3838-8 have ever been encountered
however all of the other tribes know of
them and many refer to them as the enemy
at the great battle but no tribe hates
them more than the warriors of
scp-3838-4
who know them as the enemy above all
enemies and unfortunately due to
scp-3838-4's warlike nature the
foundation has learned very little about
this mysterious rival that is until 2011
contact with scp-3838-4
is rare especially non-hostile contact
which is why it was a surprise when a
member of the tribe approached the
nearby research base with no army and no
weapons he claimed to be an envoy a
rarity for a tribe with little use for
diplomats but he wanted to speak with
the site director and thus he was
granted an interview with dr rizvi the
tribesmen was uncommunicative and
reserved at first it seemed as though he
was having trouble trusting dr rizvi but
after a bit of prodding by the doctor
the envoy warmed up to him and began to
speak what he shared was shocking there
was a long history of mistrust between
the foundation and
scp-3838-4 with many deaths on both
sides but the envoy was now insisting
that there had been a purpose for their
raids he even seemed to regret the
killings of other tribes and referred to
them as brother but he was there for a
purpose he wanted to talk about the
great battle and he referred to the
aftermath this strange place out of time
not as a tribe or as a territory but as
a prison he claimed that they were
imprisoning something in a pocket of
time and something else another part of
the whole in another reality and they
were the only ones who knew they guarded
it ruthlessly and they guarded it alone
their only partner in this lonely battle
was scp-3838-7
and their tribe was gone now their
burden was such that the other tribes
would see them as bloodthirsty monsters
but they were anything but they were the
only ones keeping the actual
bloodthirsty monsters at bay at least
that was what the story he gave while
wearing the skins of his enemies it was
impossible to make a firm deal because
of the lack of information but the envoy
was desperate he claimed that he was
bound by a higher power to not tell the
full story but he asked the foundation
to serve as an intermediary to help them
unite the tribes his desperation was
clear dr rizvi was still skeptical but
he agreed to meet with the other tribes
in the end the tribes were able to
receive agreed-upon concessions and in
return
scp-3838-4 stopped its campaign of
war-like expansion all seem to be well
until a new document was discovered
foundation operative john callahan was
involved in the marketplace period
during the 19th century and he wrote
down a translation of a song he heard
repeatedly while it was known by many
tribes legend has it that it originated
with scp-3838-8
one of the only known pieces of culture
from the mysterious tribe it spoke of a
mysterious being named the crimson khan
who would one day return when seven
seals were open they forget the hollowed
words upon the death of time may they
share the fate of those who deny to me
what's mine they forget the howling
chains that bind me safe away
one of many old cheniens forgotten in
this way
they forget the steel swords they use to
cast me down they shall not forget again
before my flaming crown they forget the
seven brides that wait for my return
such loveliness is lost upon the
children of the urns they forget the
seals that are used to keep me still
only one remembers and is not bent to my
will seven seals seven tribes six
reclaimed
one shall be mine and air the end of all
your days the crimson khan shall ride
but who is the crimson khan researchers
note a lot of similarities between this
unknown entity and the scarlet king one
of the scp-001 proposals could they be
one and the same the foundation is
keeping a close eye on the situation
with a perimeter established one
kilometer away from the tribe's
territory one entrance is available for
contact between the foundation and the
tribes but the perimeter is heavily
armed in case
scp-3838-4 gets aggressive again or in
case any other threat emerges the
foundation is on diplomatic relations
with the current occupying tribe of
scp-3838-3
but there are continued efforts at
engaging the tribe that will be their
successor the foundation has a hands-off
policy with regards to conflicts between
the tribes with
one exception the foundation is keeping
a close eye out for any members of
scp-3838-8
with orders to detain and interrogate
them on site but none have ever been
seen and in fact the foundation doesn't
even know what to look for if they are
as powerful as believed given their
feared reputation they may already be
here infiltrating the other tribes but
the foundation is determined to learn
more about them and whatever they're
bringing with them they just hope to do
it before the crimson con whoever he may
be
makes his presence known
for more on another mysterious and
dangerous group check out scp-18c
the crew of the hms wintershire or watch
scp-4007
unit 731 for another unusual group of
warriors